I mean for myself I feel like everyone
has such a different experience with the
job even in you know an interview like
this or even in a conversation with one
person it's very important to keep in
mind that all Muslim women are different
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have worn a hijab on religious
occasions but I have never actually worn
a hijab on a daily basis so this is a
new experience for me
I am half Egyptian half focsani I'm
really excited about the job day today
especially when walking back from class
I see like a lot of other people wearing
a job so it's kind of like a way that
there's more people that look like me to
be honest
I'm one of many individuals who were
very ignorant to what a ha job was or
what a job means why women wear her jobs
and I feel a lot of individuals are the
same way and I'm curious I look at the
girls and I'm curious at why she went up
I always want to ask but I'd never do
because I feel like maybe it's
disrespectful maybe she won't like that
wearing the hijab over here is different
wearing it in the Middle East in a sense
that like over here you kind of have to
initiate practicing your religion more
you know when you see other hijabis you
kind of feel like well we are kind of
not the majority in this country so it's
kind of like coming together wearing the
hijab can sometimes be considered a
cultural thing you'll see different
cultures practicing modesty and their
active worship in different ways I want
to support my Muslim sisters I want to
understand what they're experiencing
throughout the day what they've
experienced with their life and
hopefully like I'll find ways to better
support them
I'm waiting for one of my friends to
come because I have class with her and
she's never seen me in a job so I'm
excited to see what she's gonna say did
you recognize me
I'll recognize you through your voice
just come my head top on I'm so excited
but I'm so nervous too
I feel like this is probably what a lot
of Muslim women feel when they first
decide to wear a job they feel very
nervous because this is something they
haven't done before but also very
excited because they're making this
choice and this is something that they
want to do how does it feel seeing a lot
of people rank Ajay it's so comforting
and beautiful I'm participating in this
event because I think it's important to
show that I as a woman who I am NOT
Muslim but I stand with my Muslim
sisters and expressing their religion in
any way they want because in this time
especially there have been a lot of hate
crimes that have been religiously
motivated racially motivated so we just
came out from the airport this over here
is my brother I want to go pick him up
when I was at the airport
I definitely got some like looks and
stares but it wasn't as intense as I
thought it was gonna be but you
definitely have people that don't really
look at your eyes they just kind of like
look at the scarf and like the like look
away afterwards which is which is Neil I
think I just had my first negative there
I was crossing the street and there was
a lady yes anyhow the other side and she
was staring at me and I smelled her her
she didn't smile back
she just stared really hard thankfully
living in Southern California there
hasn't been a time where I felt afraid
of wearing hijab but there isn't a day
that goes by where I'm not afraid for my
sister's Muslim women are the biggest
target largest target for someone who is
Islamophobic because we are outwardly
Muslim there is no hiding the fact that
I practice the fate of Islam and so if
somebody wants to do some sort of hate
acts towards me they're going to go
towards someone who is wearing hijab one
thing that we found interesting because
we're the only huge Abbie's that are
social to class and all of our classes
and you basically yeah all of our
classes but specifically that class the
teacher uses political examples a lot
especially after the Trump election the
travel
yeah so yeah and people like look at
Titus to get our baby Muslims in here
yeah I remember in my discussion class
right when I walked in it was like the
day after the election my TA asked
basically like oh how are you feeling I
mean it was a nice gesture but is also
like you've been Hagen's I can't repeat
that I feel like my classmates have
noticed even the ones I don't talk to
the ones that I do know personally and
know me were the only ones that really
asked me about it I came to wash my
hands I was gonna like check out my hair
and stuff because that's what I usually
do when I look at myself in the mirror
in the bathroom but I I this is great I
didn't even have to do anything a lot of
the women who I spoke to today we're
talking about wearing it as a choice and
as sort of a liberating feeling and one
of them talked about how she felt it was
like a very unique way of being
beautiful to be modest and beautiful at
the same time and she felt her brought
her closer to God and I'm not a
religious person but I still think
that's a very beautiful sentiment
and here we have an academy on campus
makes me so happy there's a lot of
people outside today just on my last
class and I'm on my way to the
reflection I have to say actually got a
lot more
looks outside of the school there's so
many different types of people there's
some different types of beauty and this
is one of them and I'm glad I had the
opportunity to be a part of this today
[Music]
overall I was very fortunate to have
like a very positive day and I was very
happy with the way things today turned
out I had so many smiles and so many
affirmations like from you know females
and males off campus and on campus there
was two experiences that probably
weren't as positive or I wasn't
expecting I was at a stoplight and there
was a lady on the other side we crossed
the street and she continued she
followed me I wasn't I thought she'd
look away but she followed me and she
stayed at me very intensely and just
like very serious and there I felt so
much attention I just looked away I
didn't know what to expect I felt kind
of not I don't want to say threatened
but I just felt very uncomfortable in
that moment but I just thought about
after that I reflected like I wonder if
this is just the beginning like this is
just me one day at this moment and I
just wonder like if this is what many of
the Muslim women who wear her jobs go
through on a daily basis or maybe like
once a day or once a week they get this
and like this type of interaction with
someone and with me I already felt
uncomfortable I didn't like it and to
think that this is what they have to go
through all the time just because they
have a headscarf I didn't I don't
understand it and I think that's what
today you know was they were bringing
awareness that my footage basically was
about just like really being happy and
excited when I saw more hijabis on
campus like I haven't seen them before
because I majority of ly know all the
job is at the school so I saw new people
I'm like wow like I kinda feel like I
blend in now and also like just like at
the discussion hearing because I started
this two years ago and my first year was
a really hard experience hearing that
like you have to be very careful of what
you do and then feel like you're the
spotlight and like center of attention
and like you know like you just you have
all eyes on you
like even like I remember one of the
girls are saying like you know she was
even shy to teach in class or something
and that was me when I first started
wearing and when people understand that
difference that they just put on
themselves and see the differences that
they feel whether good or bad just felt
like you know I wasn't alone everyone
looks at the hijab as a sign of fear
perhaps or they're intimidated or the
hijab can seem very powerful and it is
but what I think I learned today the
most rewarding experience that I gained
is that it is its most basic form an act
of worship
[Music]
you
Wow
you